one of the best books I've read this
year is the expectation effect by David
Robson so he is a science writer from
the UK and he looked at a whole bunch of
studies the placebo effect which
everybody's familiar with right there is
a particular expectation that an outcome
is going to come from some sort of
medication and lo and behold that
outcome manifests he found this across
pretty much every area of anything that
you care to care about so my two
favorite studies from this so so
interesting he realized that a gluten
intolerance self-report gluten
intolerance has increased from three
percent to 30 in 10 years so this is the
why there's so many gluten-free options
on the menu they've got 30 of the
population that serve yeah so people
need it and he was wondering well what
is it human biology hasn't changed that
much is it maybe that the foods have
changed and people are responding to
that or is it maybe some sort of
expectation because the type of news
stories that are hearing about gluten
and about how bad it is for us and
inflammation and all this sort of stuff
maybe it's that people are expecting it
so they brought people into a lab they
set them down these people do and do not
have self-reported gluten intolerances
and they give everybody the same meal
they tell everybody in the room that
it's got gluten in it it's got no gluten
in it after a while people who don't
have a gluten intolerance biologically
who haven't eaten gluten
have diarrhea they have hives they're
breaking out in inflammation they're
having to run at the bathroom okay well
that's kind of interesting they did
another another story that you spoke
about VO2 max tests that they were
looking at apparently there's a
particular genetic mutation that allows
people to blow off CO2 and upregulate
oxygen in a better way they brought
people in even numbers of people that
didn't did not have this genetic trait
split them into two random groups so
there was a mix of both do and do not
have the trade in each first group was
told you've got the right genetic trait
you should be really really good at this
second group was told sorry you don't
have it you shouldn't be too good no
surprise perhaps of the group that was
told that they did they ended up
performing better but when they actually
looked at what was happening in the
physiology of these people
they found that the people who didn't
have the genetic mutation but were told
that they did had a lower overall
lactate threshold they had a lower
overall heart rate they were blowing off
CO2 more effectively and upregulating
oxygen better than the people who did
have the genetic mutation but were told
that they didn't so he coined this term
that said your expectations are even
more powerful than your genes I love
that I'm gonna read that book I that's a
remarkable example
um and I think that you know a lot these
days is being made of epigenetic effects
and things but this is almost in the
different direction this is a
psychophysiological response I find this
kind of thing to be honest among the
more fascinating and interesting aspects
of Neuroscience if not the most
interesting lately
um
those examples are tremendous so I can't
counter those at all with anything more
spectacular but that the work of Dr Alia
Crum at Stanford she runs the Stanford
Mind Body lab and she's done simple
experiments but they're really elegant
um instructing people one group all
about the terrible effects of stress
destroys your immune system etc etc
other people telling them also true
things but all the positive effects of
stress it sharpens your ability of
function you can remember things better
etc etc you see exactly what
you are told basically now you can't lie
to people you can't tell them things
that aren't true it's just about the
subset of information that you get
dictates the response you get and
perhaps the most dramatic was they gave
two different groups of people and then
they actually each got the opposite
condition to a milkshake one group is
told this milkshake is very high calorie
it contains a lot of fat and sugar Etc
another group is told uh the milkshake
they're getting is very low calorie it's
very nutrient sparse Etc then they
measure hunger so how long it takes for
them to get hungry again after ingesting
it they also look at insulin and they
also look at ghrelin this hormone that
is secreted
um as you get essentially makes you
hungry It's associated with Hunger there
are other things too but
you see exactly what you would expect
which is the people that get the
nutrient-dense milkshake are satisfied
for longer their ghrelin is suppressed
and their insulin is higher you see the
opposite in the group that had the the
so-called low calorie Shake turns out
it's the exact same milkshake
this is remarkable right because this is
not simply the placebo effect I think
it's the placebo effect plus the
expectation effect plus a real
physiological effect because that's what
you describe as well and the way that
Ali Dr Ali Crum she she goes by
the way she describes it is that any
event
causes a real physiological response but
that real physiological response is
braided in with our expectation and our
understanding of what the response ought
to be to create the actual response so
it's sort of real plus perceived equals
your reality right exactly and so um I
love this kind of thing as you can tell
I'm I'm eating up the example that uh
that you gave I think it's spectacular
because what it means is that no we
can't lie to ourselves we can't tell
ourselves that you know drinking water
is going to sustain us just as food
would for uh for five days we're not
going to be hungry but to some extent if
one understands that well you can
survive a long time on just water yeah
and you don't need to eat then you might
experience less hunger that's the way
the nervous system works well you can
definitely survive longer on just water
if you believe that you can survive
longer on just water
there is no reason not to believe this
so I was really really averse to the
whole Rhonda Byrne the secret Wu sending
out messages to the universe and David
uh positions himself very anti that as
well in the book
um but you can't deny the fact that the
positive thinking has a real
physiological impact on what you do he
was talking about um they did a study
with older people uh that were past
retirement and they asked them to use
what what sort of words do you associate
with getting older and they split these
people into two different groups and the
sort of words that people used perfectly
mapped onto how long they were going to
live so the people that use the sort of
words alone frail fragile injury death
they were the ones that lived the
shortest the people that said
um happiness Freedom Liberty connection
uh maturity those sorts of words were
the ones that lived the longest so
interesting your expectations can
literally impact your longevity there's
I am yet to read the book in detail but
I've talked to a guy named Ethan cross
he wrote a book called she's being on
the show oh fantastic I think that
internal chatter world is a very
interesting one that Neuroscience will
eventually have something to to say uh
about I think the most powerful mindset
uh at least to me is one that again I
learned from Ali Crum this is a mindset
that in her peer-reviewed studies of
different populations it's clear exists
universally in people in the SEAL Teams
but um less so or is perhaps even absent
from the general population sadly
[Music]
the idea that stress grows you that
challenge grows you but isn't the only
way that you can grow I think is a very
powerful mindset so what do you mean by
that so they she what they did is she
surveyed a bunch of different um people
different professions and asked you know
what's your view of stress do you think
it grows you it diminishes your ability
Etc so this isn't giving people
information this is asking them for
information and the only group that said
stress grows you the more challenge the
better you get Etc The more stress you
experience the more likely you are to to
succeed was the this group from the SEAL
Teams I don't know if they were new
recruits or if they had been in a long
time but that was the the group I would
add to that that yes if you adopt the
mindset that stress grows you you're
going to be much better off but also
that stress is not the only way to grow
in life right there's this idea you know
we have this and again there's sort of a
gravitational pull of this side like
stress grows yes you know forward Center
of mass or you know always be in
friction limbic friction limbic friction
how about a more
expansive or nuanced version of that
might be
stress grows you so if you're under
stress you're back on your heels from
something you think okay how can I get
flat-footed or even forward Center of
mass you tell yourself stress grows me
stress grows me stress grows me but that
doesn't mean stress is the only thing
that will grow you right learning to
cycle between periods of hard work and
deep what I call non-destructive uh
deliberate reset right
um that's what really works over time I
can attest to that you know I people who
just really go out and Tie One On In
order to to recover you can only get
away with that for a few years before
your body and mind start to give out
right so fine non-destructive ways to
reset and also adopt the mindset that
stress grows you and adopt the mindset
that you know there are other ways to
grow that don't involve stress and I
think you're set up to have a pretty
fantastic life that's my you know simple
view of of the way these things work
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace